full five round fight for 25 minutes and
the guy got hit 22 times in the face
that's insane that's a complete
domination across the board when it's
dominant like this it's tough to ask for
a rematch and and the other con that is
he has working against him is he's also
lost three what out of his last seven
he's lost two of his last three again
huge Izzy fan here look at this black
and white you go okay the guys lost two
of those last three again this wasn't
one of those fluke situations whereas
the first round first 30 seconds
Strickland goes wild catches him and
you're like ah Come run that back dude
you caught the champ you lucky shot
there's no lucky shot here there's
there's nothing lucky about this this
was a complete dismantling for 25
minutes